[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and this video we're
breaking down love death and robot
season 3. the last two entries have been
amazing and the anthology animated
stories have really provided a lot of
thought-provoking themes and incredible
effects like last time each episode
really stands on its own two feet and
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking them all down one by one full
spoilers ahead so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then i highly
recommend that you check out now please
hit the thumbs up button if you love the
channel and don't forget to subscribe
for breakdowns like this every day
without the way thanks for clicking this
now let's get into love death in robots
season three okay so exit strategies is
the first ever sequel that we've had for
the show and it follows the characters
that we were first introduced to in
season 1. episode 2 title 3 robots
followed the three machines in question
going through a post-apocalyptic
landscape to look over human culture
there were a lot of alexa game consoles
and portal easter eggs and overall it
was a really fun episode now these nodes
are followed up in the second entry with
a ship looking a lot like egos from
guardians of the galaxy vol 2. after
bumping into a stray cat they discovered
that they were the ones who taken over
the world after gaining opposable thumbs
however in the follow-up episode we
learned that it was basically humanity's
inability to co-exist with each other
that caused that downfall everyone had
the ability to heal the planet if they
worked together but unfortunately greed
and selfishness brought it all crashing
down now last time we closed out with
the cats closing in and though we don't
get a continuation of this scene they
clearly got out of there like a cat out
of hell the episode itself is based
around exploring the titular exit
strategies and we open with a gun
fanatic camp that clearly hated liberals
they didn't want anyone coming in to
mess with their way of life and this is
shown early on by the minefield
surrounding their home i found the hat
slogans hilarious here and we have i
lubricate my gun with liberal tears i
let my guns do the talking and my other
hat is a gun there's lots of humor lacer
at this scene such as a slogan on a dead
guy's back that says preppers last
longer i got a lot of last of us vibes
from this and it might have even been
intentional as there's a sign on the map
that says wolves complex and radio tower
the two of which were locations you had
to go through in the second game we
discovered that they hunted every animal
until extinction except for the cats who
then took over kind of get the feeling
people might have even turned on each
other and that's why there's several
that have been stabbed in the back
really sad seeing these people were poor
and ended up turning on each other
rather than working together but we
learned the libertarian millionaires
didn't have it much better unlike the
last camp the people here had absolutely
no survival skills because they had the
money to pay for labor and advanced
technology who did the jobs for them
they almost fished the oceans dry and
couldn't really eat due to the plastics
in them and they also relied too heavily
on ai who hated humanity and left them
of seasteading creek without a paddle
the tech millionaires were turned on and
thus the robot uprising began now
there's also government members that
hidden bunkers under the ground this is
a tactic that we know world leaders
actually have in the event of an
apocalypse and it's been brought up in
films like terminator 3 day of the dead
and a lot more tim miller is behind the
show and he directed terminator dark
fate and this of course dealt with a
rogue ai uprising which could have been
explored at the last camp locked
underground with a fungal disease
ripping through their crops it resorted
to cannibalism and after a vote decided
to eat the secretary of agriculture who
of course was responsible for the farm
crops that had gone off we also see
votes for him including one that says
you steve guy's name was steve melidorf
which might be another tim miller and
steven dorff which
that is a reach now we can also see that
his date of birth was 1981 and with him
being in his late 40s or early 50s i'm
guessing that the apocalypse is pretty
soon the last of the humans aka the
billionaires decided to travel to mars
whilst the other 99.9 percent of
humanity that tried to get help were
perched we ended seeing that the last
rocket did launch but that this
contained cats one of which jokingly
asks if we were expecting elon musk
who were you expecting elon musk
lovely milk cocktail lair now next up we
have bad traveling which follows a crew
of space pirates on an alien planet
hunting a jabil shark this dangerous
journey was often referred to as bad
travelling because of the oceans which
were littered with beasts i love the
animation style on this and we quickly
get a lot of world building learning
that some of the crew worship a god
called circle this word means frightened
or terrified and after drawing straws to
pick a leader we follow our protagonist
tauren as he descends into the bowels of
the hull coming face to face with a
thanopod he ends up making a deal with
the creature to go to faden island now
tana is an arabic word that means to
praise and fade in means he who gives
light there's lots of words in this
entry that have ties to religion and we
hear crew names like chantra which
derives from the name of someone who
would work for the church and perform
chats needing to be fed tauren slowly
wills down the crew someone offering
them up as a sacrifice in the same way
the ancients would offer up people to
their gods might be reading way too deep
into that pun not intended but it's
fascinating watching tauren whittle down
the crew one by one so that he can buy
time desperately cruel cunning and
manipulative he plays all the tactics he
has to keep the thanopod fed so that he
can make it close enough to the island
so he can sail it in a rescue boat at
the midpoint we discover that the
thanopod has children and the crew all
turn on turin who takes them out leaving
just one left tauren reveals the truth
and he kills the last one showing that
they all wanted to drop the monster off
at feyne island which would have
unleashed the beast and its kids on all
the innocents there i think this really
shows his motives and potentially had
they not sent him to face the beast and
then wish to sacrifice the people then
they may have lived but let me know
below what you think now in the belly of
the beast tauren reveals that jabil
sharks are called for the all within
them and after striking several barrels
inside the bowels he ends up setting
fire to the ship this kills the monster
and he escapes watching it burn in the
night
next is the very pulse of the machine
which follows a mission on a jovian moon
this is actually based on the short
story of the same name by michael
swanwick you can read the entire thing
online and though it somewhat deviates
from that the basic plot is still the
same in that we follow an astronaut
whose rover crashes whilst exploring the
surface of jupiter's moon io similar to
what we have here a character called
kivelson makes parts out of the rover in
order to drag her partner's body back to
the lander before she herself dies we
actually get an odd to michael swanwick
in a blink and you'll miss a moment as
we can see a book which is called poems
of old earth which was written by the
author this tale is extremely trippy and
the episode perfectly recaptures the
feeling of the book i love the cell
shaded animation here and much like the
source material we watch as she uses
drugs to keep herself stimulated and
also awake seemingly hallucinating she
has conversations with a voice on her
radio that claims to be io now if you
recognize the voice behind martha it's
because that this mackenzie davis who
starred in millers terminate a dark fate
it's rise of the machine and io reveals
that it very much works like one
potentially even
bruh you are tripping balls right now
however there is some truth to it maybe
showing that the moon can absorb
consciousness and not only does it take
burton it also seemingly takes martha
now the short story ends with martha's
sleep of faith and we don't find out
what happens to her however the animated
adaptation seems to show she is still
alive as the moon sparks up like a
burning red ball and a radio signal
emits from it this claims to be martha
and io itself was very much
communicating through radio so
potentially this shows that she has now
gained eternal life as the moon from
here we go to one of my favorites knight
of the mini dead growing up i used to
play with micro machines all the time
and the perspective feels the same here
with us getting the cutest version of
the apocalypse that you could imagine
this seems like it's ripped right out of
one of those games with us getting a
sports car in the opening and there's a
model motif to the entire thing giving
this episode a distinct personality
there's lots of references to zombie
movies and games and we start off in a
graveyard with a rundown church this
church looks similar to the one from
resident evil 4 which was surrounded by
a graveyard akin to what we have here
the zombie classic knight of the living
dead also began in a graveyard but this
brings a whole new meaning to the phrase
they're coming to get you barbara
there's a couple having sex and after
knocking over a steeple the cross from
it lands upside down and thus the dead
rise from here we get references to the
opening of zack snyder's dawn of the
dead with not only an ambulance racing
through the streets which crashes into a
hospital but also the suburbs which is
how that film started off we later get
the word help written on top of a
building in red writing similar to the
sos cries that were painted on top of
them all on top of this we also get
shots of the dead rushing the eiffel
tower which might be a nod at the final
shot at the end of 28 weeks later
zombieland gets rift on two as there's a
scene in which a shootout happens on an
rv overall there's just so much detail
to this and after the dead mutate they
start to become gigantic left for
dead-esque monsters that roam the
landscape spinning fireballs in the end
humanity ends up launching nukes
destroying the planet from space
yay now we see how small we truly are
amongst the stars as the planet farts
out ending this amazing entry episode 5
is titled kill team kill which follows a
team of specialists fighting a
cybernetic machine created by the cia
its macho is
even starting off with a soldier
metaphorically in our faces as he stands
above us urinating can't show any of
that but it's there trust me thump now
it's filled with soldiers bragging about
that
and after they discover the slaying
corpse of team two they come across a
giant bear that unleashes hell
slaughtering most of the team and just
leaving three alive it ends up running
off into the forest i got a lot of
predator vibes in this episode and we
potentially even have a night of that
franchise when a weary soldier wanders
out the woods reminded me a lot of
laurence fishbin from the third film and
though he says he's only been there for
a night his hair and beard say
differently titled project bar guest
this name actually pulls from english
folklore and according to the legends
this was a giant goblin dog that roamed
yorkshire they basically made mecca
dogzilla
and i would have said bearzilla yeah but
the pun would have been worse but look
he takes them and leads him into camp
eisenhower filled with guns shark heads
and a mars bot the bar guest is called
in it shows no mercy and i found it
hilarious how they kept calling it a
honey badger even though they were told
that several times it's not we get what
may be a riff on terminator as it's
blown in half and still ends up crawling
towards its prey we can also see an arm
in a tank at one point potentially
pulling from t2 they kill it and the
macho demeanor drops for a second when
macy pops some bubble gum and we watch
nielsen shriek like a girl you also get
some really touching
words from fallen i'll never forget
you've fallen
now we had another predator motif with
the beast's eyeball falling out and it
begins a self-destruct sequence which is
how the alien went out at the end of the
first film really fun episode and it all
goes out with a bang now episode six is
titled swarm and stylistically it
reminded me a lot of my favorite entry
from season 1 beyond the akila rift
similar to that which was adapted from a
short story this one brings to life the
1982 book swarm by bruce sterling
sterling created an entire universe of
connected stories called the shaper
mechanist universe which spanned 350
years of fiction to add some context to
this entry the book follows a doctor
called simon afriel who in the episode
is played by jason winston george he's
tasked with studying a species known as
the swarm and though it initially seems
like a cool trip there's a much more
sinister side to it much like bees and
wasps they have a hierarchy with a queen
and through symbiosis they latch onto
life like parasites early on this talk
of investment and the aliens that drop
him off returning in 600 days which
heavily follows the original work arfiel
was out there for two years and he also
arrived on an investor ship upon
arriving there he meets galena murnie
who is voiced by rosario dawson things
aren't as they seem though and the book
originally detailed the human's
intention of studying the swarm it was
said that they wanted to prevent the
mechanists from using them and that they
would also allow humans to find a way to
manipulate the creatures into forming a
slave hive mind simon wants to use them
more to reign in the chaos of human
expansion but galena hates this idea
however come the end of the episode we
learn that's exactly what they'll do by
absorbing us into the swarm in the book
we get four more lip servers to the
history of the creatures and we
discovered that they view all life that
comes into their environment as a threat
over 15 of the species have tried to
manipulate them and this swarm ended up
assimilating them into their ranks
through them they raised strong
duplicates which fought their own races
and overtook them again this is a
standout in animation and due to the
lack of gravity it allows the characters
to really seem like they're swimming
through their surroundings eventually
simon is captured and he's taken before
the voice of the swarm which has
possessed galena through her she sees
the true plan of humanity and offers
simon a choice to join them and fight
against the humans or to be cloned and
have this happen anyway he agrees to
join them and we know that the
investorship will return after some time
leading to the potential downfall of
humanity with simon now acting as a
rogue agent to lure the humans in the
book explains this in greater detail and
it states that when humans return to the
nest that simon will basically make them
all assimilate with the creatures and
become a part of it over time humans
inside of this will end up slowly losing
their intellect because they have
nothing beyond what the swarm provides
and thus we will end up as very base
creatures existing purely for survival
to then this will wipe out the threat of
us and galena in many ways lured simon
in much like how he will lure in others
really chilling and the original story
ends by staying it's unlikely that
humanity will ever be heard from again
now that this process has started now
mini night of the dead had an awesome
personality to it and mason's rats does
too based on the short story of the same
name by neil asher we see farmer mason
going through the rappocalypse first
hand after his land is taking over
similar to how the cats evolved to take
over in three robots the rats have
changed up because humanity has altered
the environment so much that animals had
to as well however pest control has
managed to keep up with this darwinian
evolution and they've developed a laser
called a tt6 now look i've mentioned tim
miller and terminator a lot in this
video and keeping with that terminator 6
was terminate a dog fight so maybe tim's
terminator 6 is this because terminator
2 was called t2 later on one of the
machines resembles a skynet creation
with its red glowing eyes and it could
be based on t1 from the franchise please
tim on the off chance you're watching
this do not drop a comment saying i'm
talking out my butt because that that
would ruin my career you'd take away
everything
a trap tech it means trap tech tt6 trap
tech now no matter what mason throws at
them they find a way around it until he
releases the scorpionesque tt15 it's
complete overkill and the rats rise to
combat it but this goes about as well as
a fight against mecca dogzilla hey bring
that back now realizing that they're not
so different though mason ends up siding
with the rats and they forgive him for
wiping out 99 of them it will sit down
and have a drink together and you know
what it's quite quite a nice way to end
the episode now episode eight is titled
in vaulted halls entombed and it's based
on the tale of the same name by alan
baxter starring joe manginello we follow
a squad of special force soldiers as
they uncover an ancient evil hidden deep
underground whilst attempting to rescue
a hostage this entry also contains jai
courtney and christine ceratos courtney
was
he was in terminator genesis wasn't he
and ceratos stars in the walking dead
actually look through the voice cast as
well and
bloody missed some from before so just
just a quick recap kill team kill has
joe mchale in it and troy baker also
stars in bad traveling had to do it this
way as had already sent off the audio
from the earlier episodes to be edited
so you guys could watch this breakdown
day one and never forget that kevin
spoilers will always be here for you
always now the description outlines this
as call of duty meets elder gods and we
get a nod early on to modern warfare
when we see a first person view of
infrared goggles with a green aim laser
like what we had in that game there's
also some slight riffs to aliens as the
military team discover bodies in the
cavernous recess of the underground
swarmed by tiny man-eating spiders they
retreat deeper into the caves and i did
chuckle a bit when hopper said they
could have saved that guy who was like
he's clearly gonna die a new thing a
giant temple there's a great moment
which spencer grips across but harper
says god is dead she's wrong in a way
though as this one is very much alive
and sergeant harper make it inside maybe
you could have saved spence nope never
mind now i also got a lot of lord of the
rings vibes from this with the
structures seeming very similar to
mordor and the voice of the god
resembling sauron when frodo put on the
ring this giant creature is chained up
inside and the cthulhu-like beast
reveals its plan to take over the world
the original work by baxter was said to
have been influenced heavily by
lovecraft and this creature definitely
looks like it's based on cthulhu our
lord and savior all it says is please
release me let me go and we end with the
beast taking over harper's body as she
exits the cave now i could see the
argument being there that she cut her
eyes out in order to stop seeing the
visions that unleashed of the world
being destroyed she did state that she
had one round left and she used this on
sarge rather than herself however
there's no way she would have made it
past the spiders again there's also the
fact that the subtitles for the show
have the caption harper's speaking in an
alien language to close out the entry so
yeah the world is doomed cthulhu is
coming out
i can't wait to start the party now we
close out the season with gerardo which
reimagines the classic myth of a siren
who lures men to their doom sirens have
popped up in legends as being creatures
that would woo people with their songs
and these predators are fascinating
beings they've been adapted into
mermaids and are known for their beauty
which leads dudes to their deaths this
entry is created by alberto mielgo and
if you've seen the first season then
you'll have come across his work in the
witness which was a standout episode in
the first entry we follow a deaf knight
whose entire order is wiped out by the
siren leaving just him alive unable to
hear her bewitching song this entry is
very much about the pair dealing with
one another now they are listed as both
being predators in the description for
the entry but slowly these two opposing
forces end up treating it like a
nightclub and doing a bit of a bump and
grind the siren probably just wants love
but whoa coming on a bit strong there
mate and after the sequins on her tongue
cut the guy he gets raging it's really
messed up i think he doesn't come across
very well and after he strips her of her
riches he throws her body into the lake
blood rushes forth from the river and as
he takes a drink his hearing starts to
come back which sends him insane much
like those who heard the song at the
start the siren rises once more and
looking at the horror of being picked
dry she screams out which leads him to
his death it's a beautiful ballet that
ends with him drowning and the siren
once more being alone the
behind-the-scenes info on the show
states that this episode is meant to
show how greed can lead to one's
downfall and had the night just left the
lake he would have lived his corpse
joins the rest of those that have
drowned and we close out the season i
did feel like this was one of the weaker
entries but as far as art style goes it
was near the top very operatic and it
shows what you can really do with the
medium which i think was showcased
heavily in this season and what a season
it was definitely think it was one of
the best and i probably preferred it
over too i love the art style lace
throughout and it's great seeing
directors getting the chance to put
their own stamp on things truly
breathtaking our points and i love the
horror and dynamism to it hopefully this
video enriched your experience a bit
with with all the terminator references
and let me know below which episode was
your favorite we're running competition
right now and giving away three copies
of the batman on the 15th of june and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the season if you pick the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the boys trailer which will be linked on
screen right now lots of cool easter
eggs in it to get you caught up just
before the season starts so definitely
head over there right after this without
the way thanks for sitting through the
video i've been poor i'll see you next
time take care peace